ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Hi, everyone.
We're here at Devoxx in
Antwerp, Belgium 2014,
and I'm here with
the Guava team.
Can I call you guys
the Guava team?
GREGORY KICK: Certainly
members of it.
There are seven of us in
total, but just the two today.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Just seven.
Not one more.
So do you guys want to
introduce yourselves
and say what you
focus on in Guava?
And there's more to Guava.
I introduced you as Guava, but
you're the Java Google team.
You do a number of projects.
Define what you do, really.
KURT KLUEVER: Sure.
GREGORY KICK: We are officially
Google's Java Core Libraries
Team, but even that's
becoming a little less
than what we do these days.
We work on tools and
all sorts of things.
I'm Greg Kick.
Been a member of the
Java Core Libraries Team
for two or three years
now and a Googler for six,
and been contributing
to Guava since even
before I worked there.
KURT KLUEVER: I'm Kurt Kluever.
I'm the sole member
New York, and I've
been on the team for about the
same time as Greg, two or three
years, and at Google
also for six years.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
A lot of people
use Guava because it seems
to fit a need that innovates
and creates things
that people could not
find in the default
class libraries.
Eventually, Java evolves.
Tell me more about why
people use Guava today,
and maybe with Java 8
being out, lambda streams,
how things might be changing.
KURT KLUEVER: Guava is going
to pretty drastically change
when we eventually
switch to Java 8.
A lot of stuff has been
obsoleted and a lot of stuff
needs to change.
Actually, we haven't even
made the jump to Java 8
yet at Google, so
we've got a lot
to work on to restructure
all the libraries
and get rid of stuff that's
been obsoleted and whatnot.
There's going to be a
lot of change coming.
GREGORY KICK: There's
two sides to that coin.
For Android specifically and
supporting legacy platforms,
we are going to be in a pre-Java
8 world for a very long time.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: You
still have a Java 6 requirement
today and you'll keep
that for a long while.
GREGORY KICK: Right.
We're not going to drop our
Android users on the floor
anytime soon.
We plan to support them
for as long as practical.
But on the other side of
that, looking towards Java 8,
the library as it stands,
a lot of the things that
are included-- the
function interface,
the predicate interface--
those are all single method
interfaces that are perfectly
compatible with lambdas
and those types of things,
and that's no accident.
Java 8 was designed with
some of those legacy
compatibilities in mind.
A lot of the things will just
work straight out of the box,
but we have another
teammate, Louis Wasserman,
who's been doing nothing
but working on figuring out
how to make streams fit
into Guava and lambdas fit
into Guava and make sure that
all of the collections that we
provide are compatible.
I believe that those are
available in the open source?
KURT KLUEVER: Yeah.
I think he has a project
on Git Hub already
that has Guava
building with Java 8
and actually has a lot of
inter-op working already.
GREGORY KICK: Right.
So I'm sure that some
combination of "Louis Wasserman
GitHub Guava,"
that Google search
will get you to some new
content if you're interested.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: Just
use your favorite search tool.
I read somewhere that
you guys are actually
removing deprecated
methods, which
seems very awkward and
different for people that
are used to the
classic Java libraries.
Tell me more about how it's
working for you and your users.
KURT KLUEVER: Sure.
At least internally,
we are pretty
aggressive about removing
bad APIs or legacy APIs.
And actually, with a
lot of the stuff that's
going into Java these days with
Java 7 and Java 8 especially,
there's a lot of stuff
that's been obsoleted.
So we do pretty
aggressively remove stuff.
At least our policy in
the open source Guava
is if it's a non-beta
API, we give it
18 months to just leave
it in the deprecated state
to get users to
switch off of it.
If it's a beta API,
the beta annotation
really just means non-frozen.
So if it's a non-frozen API,
we typically say one release,
but it typically ends up
being two or three that
will give you time
to move off of it.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
And have you
had people complain about it?
How does it work for
your users, really?
GREGORY KICK: This
isn't, oh, we decided
we don't like this thing.
We're deleting it.
The best example
that I can think of
is we used to have for a long
time a class called char sets.
People work with char sets
to read files into text
all the time, and we made
it convenient to have
constants for things like UTF 8.
Java 7, I believe, introduce
standard char sets,
and now the exact same
equivalent functionality
was in the JDK, so it
didn't make sense for us
to keep our entirely
functionally equivalent version
around in Guava if the JDK is
already providing it for you.
So that was a case where it
was clear to start the removal
process just to give people
one option rather than two.
Decisions like that are
usually pretty uncontroversial.
KURT KLUEVER: Actually, one
of the more controversial
decisions we've had is
all the static factory
methods for collections.
We have list.newArrayList,
which people
love to use to thwart the
necessity for generics
on the right hand side
of the assignment.
Of course, that's been
obsoleted with the dot operator,
so we've had this
really tough decision
to make internally whether we
just leave those methods there
and let people
continue to use those
or if we just force
them to use the diamond
operator with the collections.
I think that's still in flux.
I don't know what the
final decision there is.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Cast your votes.
GREGORY KICK: But we always
try to listen to user feedback,
whether it's internally
or externally,
and make the decisions
that make people happiest.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Let's switch gears a little bit.
So Guava is lots
of different things
for lots of different people.
Let's not get into how we
modularize Guava discussion.
There's plenty of things you
can read online about it.
Dagger.
So Dagger and dependency
injection, not something new.
The concept has been
around for a long time,
whether it's Pico,
Spring, and Dagger now,
Dagger 2, even, I hear.
Tell me how we got
to this and why
did we have all
these generations,
and what is the problem
you're trying to solve?
GREGORY KICK:
First of all, kudos
for remembering PicoContainer.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
I'm sorry.
GREGORY KICK: Not too
many people do these days.
I just recently
gave a presentation.
There's a good history
on how we arrived.
Dependency injection
is great, and we've
used it to great effect.
Juice is probably one of the
most widely used frameworks
within Google, has
tons of adoption
and lets us make very large
apps very effectively.
But the chief
complaint has always
been that because you
do all the configuration
of your dependency
injection at runtime,
it can be a bit of a mystery
how your application lays out.
When you build up very,
very large applications,
like Google Docs and
things like that,
debugging can be
a bit of a trick.
When you see an
issue in production
and you don't really know
why things were configured
the way that they are, reasoning
about why that may or may not
be from your code
can be difficult
if all your configuration
happens at runtime.
So Dagger 1 was a step in
the right direction where
it used code generation rather
than reflection to statically
configure some of these
different dependency injection
options, and you could start
to inspect more and more, just
in your code base at compile
time, rather than at runtime.
Dagger 2 is the next evolution.
Dagger 1 was originally
developed by Square
with contributions from Google.
Now Dagger 2 is mostly
developed at Google
with contributions from Square,
and it is a fully compile time
solution.
Everything about your
dependency injection graph
is all written down statically.
From the very high
level entry point
to your application, all the way
through the graph to the very
lowest level node,
you can navigate
using things like find
usages and open declaration
in Eclipse.
So for the first
time ever, we've
gotten rid of all
the dynamism that
was causing a lot of
issues, and we now
have an entire
application laid out
at compile time
that survives things
like ProGuard in your mobile
environments and obfuscation
because you have the entire
application written down
as just pure, simple Java code.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
So from a developer
perspective, does
that change anything?
You have injection points.
Do you have additional
features, or do you actually
have less features, maybe?
Maybe compare that with Juice.
GREGORY KICK: Absolutely,
there is a trade off.
We don't have a lot
of features that
were solely reflection based.
We're viewing that is a
good thing because there's
a lot fewer places where you
might get a little confused,
but some people that
used heavy use of AOP,
the aspect-oriented programming,
where you could dynamically
change behavior at runtime,
there's no support for that.
Anything where you were changing
the shape of your dependencies
based on a runtime flag,
there's no support for that.
We've got a lot of
work alike solutions
for many of the patterns that
people found that they needed,
and we've been able to run
large search applications.
Large portions of
the search stack
have been fully
implemented using Dagger 2,
so we're confident
that there are
solutions to all
of the problems.
They might just not
look exactly the same
as they did with Juice.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
You mentioned Square
as the initial
writers and developers
of the first version of Dagger.
Is this whole thing really
mobile driven and mobile only
as a solution, or
could you see Dagger 2
specifically elsewhere,
and maybe supporting
things like servlets?
Does it make any sense.
GREGORY KICK: Absolutely.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE POUCHKINE:
I mean, fast startup
is one of the
things you also get.
Because of that, you're
not doing all that class
scanning and generating code
at startup or at runtime,
so I'm sure that works
well in the cloud, too.
Everybody likes fast startups.
GREGORY KICK: Yeah,
nobody ever complains
about good performance.
While we have,
certainly within Google,
a lot of mobile applications
running Dagger, like I said,
Dagger 2 specifically powers
a pretty large portion
of the search stack.
When we transitioned from
Dagger 1 to Dagger 2,
we actually saw a 13%
improvement on per request CPU.
Fast search results
is what we do,
and Dagger 2 is now
part of that solution,
and that's been
pretty rewarding.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE POUCHKINE:
Where's Dagger 2 now?
Can you give us a status?
GREGORY KICK: Dagger
2 is still building
from head for the most part.
We haven't had quite
the 2.0 release yet.
We expect to have a feature
complete, bug more or less free
beta version coming soon,
but right now, you just
have to pull it down from
GitHub and built from head.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE
POUCHKINE: Sounds good.
Switching gears once again, how
about we talk about something
called Truth?
I've heard about
it, but really, you
need to tell me and
probably everybody
else what this is about.
KURT KLUEVER: Sure.
So it's a fluent assertion
library based on JUnit
that we've been using for
a couple years now inside
of Google.
We've been focusing on it
for about six months now,
and we've really been driving
the adoption and change
in the API from a bunch of
legacy assertion libraries
that we had inside of Google.
So we had this one, maybe
200 different static assert
methods, assert blasts or all
these different assert methods.
It was just a big grab
bag of assertion methods
that users just
couldn't navigate
because it was just way
too big and complex.
So we have evolved
the Truth library
to fit the needs
for these users.
We've been, like I said,
focusing on it for probably
about six months now, and
driving the adoption of Truth
by migrating those
legacy users to this API.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE: OK.
So that's yet another project
that you're working on.
Where is that at today?
KURT KLUEVER: That's
open source is well.
We haven't really even
set goals for when
we're going to do a 1.0
release or anything like that,
but we've been doing snapshot
releases and stuff like that.
It's all being synced
up to GitHub as well.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Any external committers,
external interest?
KURT KLUEVER: There's
certainly interest out there.
I don't know that
we've had a whole lot
of external committers, but--
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Any call to action?
What should people
expect and look at?
KURT KLUEVER: I mean, they
can certainly test it out,
and if they have any
feature requests,
submit those as issues.
We've had a handful
of good ideas come
from external
contributors as well.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
So just ideas and you
implement, right?
You do the work.
KURT KLUEVER:
Typically, that's--
GREGORY KICK: And I'm going
to give a little sales pitch
on Kurt's behalf.
A lot of people will
ask, assertion libraries
have been around forever.
Why don't I just
use JUnit to search?
Why don't I use AspectJ or--
KURT KLUEVER: AssertJ.
GREGORY KICK: AssertJ.
That's the one.
AssertJ or Fest or Hamcrest
or whatever it may be.
The big selling point of Truth
is that its fluent assertion
library is also very
pluggable, very modular.
For Dagger, we've
been using Truth
to be able to test
our annotation
processors because we
were able to build in,
just spun a quick little project
called Compile Testing that
lets us now hook into the
fluent chain assertions
about annotation
processors and the results
of your compilation.
And because you can very
quickly and easily add new bits
to the chain for
your specific types,
we found Truth to
be really powerful.
So whether it's things
like protocol buffers,
or your new fancy collection,
the Guava collections
like Multimap and
Multiset, we can now
build in extra
assertions as we go
rather than having to
recompile a whole new version
of the library and make a
new static method somewhere.
KURT KLUEVER: And those
custom assertions, like Greg
alluded to, people on
their own smaller projects,
they can make these
domain specific languages
and make the assertions
exactly how they
would read it in fluent English.
So we've had teams
all over Google
making their own
plug-ins to Truth
to make their assertions
read a lot better.
But inside of core
Truth, we basically
have assertions about
a lot of the JDK types,
and also a lot of the
Guava types as well.
It has a dependency
on Guava, so we're
adding custom subjects for
all those Guava types as well.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE
POUCHKINE: Sounds good.
Before we close-- we
only have so much time.
We could go on.
I have a lot of questions,
but maybe one final question.
You've been living and breathing
Java for years, it seems.
Where do you see
Java in five years?
GREGORY KICK: That's
a tricky question
because, at least
as far as the things
we've seen, the things that
I've personally worked on,
we've been very satisfied with
the state of the libraries.
We've settled to a pretty
decent, steady state
with just contributing
new libraries
and having people
consume them that way,
but a big increase in tool
driven pseudo libraries.
Dagger 2 is entirely
annotation processor based.
AutoValue, which
is a great project,
and some of the
other Auto projects
that generate code based
on annotations for you
and take out a lot of
that boilerplate, that's
been very quickly becoming
the go to solution
for a lot of problems that
were left unsolved previously.
So I see more and more people
writing less and less code,
and lambdas and streams
seem to be in that vein,
too, where you used
to have to write
big, bulky anonymous
inner classes, where
now nice, convenient
cheap lambdas.
KURT KLUEVER: Java is no longer
this ceremonious language.
GREGORY KICK: Less
and less of that.
So I frankly expect
that in five years,
we will be writing the same type
of code, just much less of it.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE
POUCHKINE: Sounds
like a bright future to me.
Thanks, guys, for doing this,
and enjoy the conference.
GREGORY KICK: Excellent.
Thanks.
KURT KLUEVER: Thank you.